Now you've probably heard of the
Leidenfrost effect. That's when a
volatile droplet like water
levitates over a hot surface because
it's floating on a little cushion of its
own vapor. Here I'm gonna try to create
the inverse Leidenfrost effect where we
levitate a droplet on a bath of liquid
nitroge. It's inverse because the droplet
is not actually creating the vapor, it's
the bath beneath, it's the liquid
nitrogen that's creating the vapor.
There have been a couple of recent papers
about this phenomenon so I called up one
of the scientists to ask how can I do
this and how does it work?
hello -hi -hi, how are you?
Good, and you? -I am doing very
well.
So, I was gonna ask you, do you think I
would be able to replicate this without
too much difficulty? If you have liquid
nitrogen. yes. It's it's really simple.
it's really basic what you need is a
polystyrene box like 20 by 20
centimeters. A bit thick so that it insulates
and then I had two beakers one like that
size and another one that is smaller in
which the experiments... ah yeah. I will put him away
Um, so two beakers...
okay so when you
have a look at this setup I have a piece
of styrofoam that has a cylindrical
cutout in it into which I have poured
some liquid nitrogen and the purpose of
that is to get this outer space as cold
as possible and insulated from the rest
of the air. Then I have this large beaker
that is full of liquid nitrogen. As you
can see, it is boiling and then I have
the innermost beaker which is not
boiling so I have still liquid nitrogen
in the middle that is not boiling and
that is what I want because that is
where we can actually conduct the
experiment and try to get the inverse
Leidenfrost effect to work.
Okay I have
100 microliters of silicone oil and I'm
gonna attempt to drop it onto this bath
of liquid nitrogen whoa oh my God look
at that. what?!
there were a whole bunch of droplets and
they were all levitating on the surface.
Now that they are in there now the
liquid nitrogen is boiling so this is
not good...
hey, future Derek here. Sorry my hair
looks stupid I'm gonna go get it cut
but that last experiment didn't go very
well because the liquid nitrogen in the
middle beaker was boiling and there was
nothing I could do about it so I tested
a few droplets on there but you couldn't
really see the effect nicely because of
that boiling bath so I'm gonna try again
today clean beakers new liquid nitrogen
let's give it a shot
there it is, got a droplet of silicone
oil and it is bouncing around back and
forth. That is pretty cool!
What's amazing
about this effect is that it can
continue almost indefinitely. It's been
observed to last for tens of minutes
unlike the Leidenfrost effect where the
droplet is used up making the vapor
cushion that supports it, here the
supporting vapor comes from the bath so
it can continue indefinitely even after
the drop has frozen.
The heat required to
evaporate the bath comes not only from
the droplet but also from the warm
atmosphere around the experiment.
although on my second attempt I was able
to prevent the small beaker of liquid
nitrogen from boiling, my setup was a bit
unstable so the boiling in the outer
beaker shook the inner beaker
interfering with the droplets motion but
in Anaïs's professional setup you can
see how the drop always moves in
straight lines. But why should the
droplet be moving at all? and what keeps
it moving?
A lot of people have been putting drops on  a bath and have observed the
movements but nobody has tried to
explain it, like yet.
So how did you explain it?
there is something that happens at the
interface so you have a floating drop
with a thin vapor layer above the bath
and then what seems to happen is that
this vapor layer is not uniformly thick
but then at some point there is a like a
tiny instability like a capillary wave
that grows under it.
but why is there a wave?
just for example because you'd
never deposit the drop perfectly,
nicely and smoothly so you you create
tiny waves that come back below the drop
I think you can see that here as I add a
droplet to the bath. Notice the waves
generated in the middle of the beaker?
These little waves lead to an asymmetry
underneath the droplet where one side is
higher than the other.
More nitrogen gas escapes out this side
Now you might
think this would drive the droplet in
the opposite direction but it doesn't.
the gas actually drags the droplet along
with it
kind of like how wind over your
windshield pushes raindrops along.
What
is great here is that this instability
instantly reappears each time the drop
comes close to a wall.
So when you have a
wall in the bath you have a small liquid
nitrogen meniscus so the drop starts to
climb it and then the propelling force
reverses and then pushes it back
And this creates a nice star pattern so
it's it's like self-propelled forever and
repelled from the walls which is which
is very cool
So do you think this
research has applications and what sort
of applications might those be?
if you imagine an embryo of an animal
like a mouse or something. A very very
young embryo is like 10 cells so it's
incredibly small. So what they do is like
they put it into liquid that allows
cryopreservation and then freeze it. and
and what is great about this is what
they do is they take the drop and put it
into liquid nitrogen and then it freezes.
what... and if the freezing is fast enough
you you don't grow ice crystals so you
preserve the embryo and what is
great about this is like if you imagine
instead of just putting an oil drop
like what I did is like you put an embryo with the cryopreservance on
the liquid bath then you can you can
make it into a canal like this and then you
can generate them like in a random way
and move them around because they are
self-propelled so they would go in the
direction that you want them to move so
you could imagine making something
where you could at the same time
freeze your cells or chemicals and then
move them along without generating any
contaminations because you're basically
not touching them
that's an interesting potential
application of this
hey this episode of veritasium was
supported by viewers like you on patreon
and by audible there's never been a
better time to start listening on
audible
you know today driving down to get my
haircut I was listening to this book: Bad
Blood: secrets and lies in a Silicon
Valley startup by John Carreyrou
it's the inside story of the company
thoroughness and its founder Elizabeth
Holmes she was this Stanford dropout who
became the head of a medical technology
company valued at around 10 billion
dollars but was her technology legit or
a massive fraud? if that sounds
interesting to you you can download this
book when you start a 30-day trial just
go to audible.com slash veritasium or
text veritasium to five hundred five
hundred or you can pick any other book
you like from audibles unmatched
selection of audio content now I like
listening in the car because I find it
makes LA traffic much more bearable but
you can listen at home or at the gym or
just on-the-go listen on any device
anytime anywhere. Every month as an
audible member you get one credit good
for any audiobook you choose plus two audible originals from a changing
selection that you can't find anywhere
else if you don't use a credit one month
it rolls over to the next month if you
don't like a book that you got you can
exchange it no questions asked and your
library is yours to keep to listen to
whenever you like even if you cancel
your membership now audible members also
get access to audio fitness and health
workouts to begin your year on the right
foot
so there's no better place to listen
than audible get started with a 30-day
trial when you go to audible.com slash
veritasium or text veritasium to 500 500
audible the most inspiring minds the
most compelling stories the best place
to listen now I want to thank audible
for supporting me and I want to thank
you for watching